partidos movimientos y organizaciones de
izquierda se manifiesta en la Plaza de
Mayo para reclamarle al gobierno del
presidente Alberto Fernández el gobierno
peronista el presidente Fernández que no
avance en un acuerdo con el Fondo
Monetario Internacional para renegociar
una deuda de 44000 billones de dólares
contraida por su antecesor
Mauricio Macri porque consideran que no
debe haber un acuerdo con el Fondo
Monetario Internacional
zona una deuda fraudulenta y nosotros
nos oponemos por qué significa la ruina
de bueno de las condiciones de vida de
los trabajadores y las trabajadoras del
país invierte ese dinero que iría al
fondo nosotros tendríamos más puesto de
trabajo y generaríamos ingreso para
poder pagar la deuda creo que de ese
lado tendría que ser el otro lado existe
un consenso especialmente entre
economistas ortodoxos y también es de
voces del oficialismo que hiciste que no
cerrar un acuerdo con el Fondo Monetario
Internacional sería peor para el país
sobre todo de cara un 2022 con miles de
millones de vencimientos con el
organismo en un contexto en el que el
país necesita desesperadamente contar
con divisas y tener que afrontar esos
pagos serían muy muy difícil o forzaría
en todo caso si no al país afrontar una
situación de cesación de pagos